here's what blew me away about Amsterdam
first of all the
bicycles dude there are it's likeing and
they're flying Zing zinging you think
they're aggressive in Portland the
Portland bicyclists are like
[__] the Amsterdam bicyclist will
punch a Portland bicyclist in the
[__] face and then pee in their mouth
as they drive by there's no slowing down
they don't Ving Zing zinging and you
just hear it's like a nightmare this
just bells ringing all over the place
and they're V Ving I saw a bicyclist hit
a tourist on foot and then everybody was
like get get out of the [__] way to
the tourist dude and the cars have to
slow down but they're driving an inch
away from the bicyclist and the
bicyclist was like No And it was pouring
rain and they're just all I was getting
into a cab in Amsterdam and guy goes
where you from I was like America and he
goes I never would have guessed that and
I said why not he goes I can usually
tell America by their fat [__] faces
is what he said and I was like yo you're
not
lying yo I that is foul I travel a lot
right I will you know the one thing you
see some heavier people you know what I
didn't see obese I didn't see obese at
all I did not see obese at all in the UK
and Europe obese I saw one or two okay
but you can see 102 one or two when we
get off the plane in Ohio we're going to
see one or two when we walk outside dude
it was shocking to me well yeah cuz
their their servings are regular size
yeah that's it that's they serve a
regular amount of food yeah it's a when
when when the first plate went down yo
cuz you know I'll eat five eggs in the
morning when we were the first place I
went and they were like go how many eggs
come and they were like two I go can I
get three more and they sit out loud you
want five eggs on the same plate yeah
and I was like not now I
don't no I want to yeah dude the the not
only the serving size but people walk
and get on their [__] bicycles yeah
because driving driving is so [__]
hard out there you we were in the cabs
you see how hard it is to drive in that
City dude in Amsterdam bicycles are the
they have the right of way over cars
yeah they just fing Bing alling on their
bikes and there but it gets confusing
because there's so many ring rings you
just don't know where they're coming
from yeah they're coming from all over
and you're high and you're like oh so
many ring rings yeah it was a little
confusing you know what somebody told me
they were like listen dude if you're
over 30 and you're Dutch and you smoke
weed people think you're a loser like y
yo what the people there aren't smoking
the weed it's just the tourists and if
you're over 30 and smoking weed there
they think you're a [__] loser that's
the way it was explained to me that
that's kid [__] now you might take some
start taking some ketamine that's some
real [__] grown-up drugs but there's
grown-up drugs and they're kid drugs and
weed there is a kid drug dude guess what
I'm sticking with my [__] kid drugs
dude I'm sticky icky I'm with you that
that is the point of being the Hub of
places one of the like weed friendliest
places in the world if none of like
you're all obviously weed friendly but
like tourist weed
enthusiastic none of you care tourists
so everybody in the coffee shop you went
to was a tourist most yeah it's like
working there there no locals dude and
it's also like you can tell the woman
behind the when she was there she was a
year American huh I said yeah how do you
know she goes you smoked that whole
joint and I was like what do you mean
that is awesome she said you know the
she said the people in the UK they take
three hits and they're like I'm so high
well yeah they can't because they they
roll splits they don't get the weed well
no no it's because they don't roll just
like joint the weed isn't as good that
too yeah but the weed we get better weed
than everybody especially
in
Amsterdam if you want good weed in the
Netherlands you don't go downtown
Amsterdam that's the tourist weed you
got to go out away so where where do you
where do you find the good wheat not
down there that's dude it was
fascinating the the way it was explained
to me but I'll tell you something right
now not one and and know this really in
Europe the when I they they give
normaliz plates of food and everybody
walks or hops on the bike I did not see
any obese people it was so alarming you
know what else
novs no enormous all the gluttonous part
of our now I'm gonna say this guys I
still think America is the best country
in the world but this trip reminded me
that that doesn't mean we don't have
things to learn and by the way guys I've
I've mentioned the obese thing I'm a
dude who thinks you
should eat and you want to be obese
that's this is your body your choice but
that doesn't mean that we also all have
to close our eyes and go it's good for
you you can be B body positive and
celebrate the way you look and wear the
clothes you want to wear but also the
reality of is you're going to die sooner
than other people you don't see any very
fat old people do you no no you don't
see any really huge old people do you no
that's a probably a very very very small
so let's let's like two things can be
true at once and nobody's saying
nobody's shaming You by saying that if
you're super big you're generally not
going to be as healthy as other people
that's just a fact right I'm I'm also
saying you enjoy yourself and celebrate
what you look like yeah but yo dude the
gluttonous part of the states the extra
big truck with the [__] huge Wheels
the SUV the huge plates of food